[Musique]
j'arrive à temps
il doit soit les voiles et la vôtre
c'était infernal
[Musique]
j'étais à fusible intérieur avec
l'allègement de maisonneuve a ou des
marqueurs
comment ça s'est passé pour vous le
débarquement
nous on aurait recommencé ont été des
gros bateaux sur la manque
et puis quand j'ai été dans notre tour
on a défendu avec les deux des coques
down
la dame est sûre on était au visage puis
oliva à riom bessa porte en avant on a
débarqué dans l'oued des automates
heures on ma chère un mach ailleurs
l'autre match nul au match retour mais
c'était début lui de tonnerre c'est l
écoute camion cupide to peace forcé dans
l'ambiance est de quoi a peur comment
tirer
avez vous perdu des hommes au moment du
débarquement
oui je peux préciser combien 6 7 1 6
juil moi jamais 18 mai 17 ans mais j'ose
le dire qu'un élève de 16 ans il avait
caché le genre avec des faux papiers
pour gta qu'un flux vieira et pif
en étant jeune je voulais faire et la
colombe là je me suis embrouillé le
talent devant 40 euros là ça fait
beaucoup de chagrin mais parra
maintenait
mais ma mère m'ont dit que je suis que
la gare à mon aviez un peu plus nancy
breau badge lancia le verrez plus si
elle est heureuse elle est décidée avant
vous revenir dessus des 40 2 une femme
fera l'amitié de deux temps d'hyères de
l'amitié d'un autre hama il ya une
russie phalange j'ai une chaulier parce
que vous avez partagé la même expérience
le souhaitions on a des gens quand on
avance et on a priori on est petit
quand j'étudiais type ans
[Musique]
ah ah
je pense pas que dans cinq ans gigean il
y avait nourri ciel et monique chez io
saluer cette spéciale parce que si la
dame hier
là vous allez aller pour les
célébrations du 75e anniversaire en
normandie
donc vous serez en normandie pour ces
cérémonies
qu'est ce que ça représente pour vous
léger motion doit enlever à bron je peux
pas expliquer ça commence que dans deux
femmes d'enfants qui vont nous prendre
l'a1 bros brawl et avec nous parce qu'on
se surprend beaucoup reason sera
ralentie c'est très important pour nous
mais les français de la demande il est
évident que les trajets partant pour ça
toutes les cérémonies du haut rhin
lebron la mort du monde
[Musique]
si les émotions allez un petit chalet
mis à la haine
chut vielle que ce que j'ai fait pour
mon pays
merci beaucoup
[Musique]